AINSLEY: PRESIDENT RESTRICTING
TRAVEL FROM EUROPE AS COVID-19
IS OFFICIALLY DECLARED A
PANDEMIC.
STEVE: VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE
JOINS US FROM WASHINGTON.
HE JOINS US LIVE.
MR. VICE PRESIDENT, GOOD MORNING
TO YOU.
AINSLEY: GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU ALL.
STEVE: WE HEARD FROM THE
PRESIDENT WHERE HE TALKED ABOUT
SOME OF THE INITIATIVES
INCLUDING FOR THE MOST PART
CUTTING OFF ALL TRAVEL FROM
EUROPE WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
ENGLAND AND IRELAND, I THINK,
THINGS LIKE THAT.
WHAT HAS BEEN THE REACTION TO
THE WHITE HOUSE OVER THE
PRESIDENT’S MOVE LAST NIGHT?
>> WELL, I THINK THE REACTION
HAS BEEN VERY FAVORABLE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
I MEAN, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
SEEN, ONCE AGAIN, THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS NO HIGHER PRIORITY
THAN THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
THE PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY.
YOU GO BACK TO WHEN THE
CORONAVIRUS FIRST EMERGED IN
JANUARY IN THIS COUNTRY THE
PRESIDENT, AGAIN, JUST LIKE HE
DID LAST NIGHT, HE TOOK
UNPRECEDENTED ACTION IN JANUARY
TO SUSPEND ALL TRAVEL FROM
CHINA.
WE QUARANTINED ANY AMERICANS
THAT WERE RETURNING FROM CHINA
TO PUT THE HEALTH OF AMERICA
FIRST.
WE ISSUED TRAVEL ADVISORIES FOR
ITALY AND FOR SOUTH KOREA.
BUT NOW THE REALITY IS THAT THE
EPICENTER OF THE CORONAVIRUS
EPIDEMIC HAS MOVED FROM CHINA
AND SOUTH KOREA TO EUROPE.
OUR TASK FORCE HAS BEEN TRACKING
THAT.
WE BROUGHT THAT INFORMATION TO
THE PRESIDENT IN REALTIME AND
YESTERDAY HE MADE THE DECISION
IN THE OVAL OFFICE SO SUSPEND
ALL TRAVEL FROM EUROPE FOR THE
NEXT 30 DAYS AND TO BE CLEAR,
STEVE, EVERY AMERICAN THAT IS
RETURNING FROM EUROPE WILL BE
SCREENED AS THEY RETURN THROUGH
13 SEPARATE AIRPORTS AND WILL BE
ASKED TO SELF-QUARANTINE FOR 14
DAYS.
STEVE: OKAY.
>> IT’S PART OF THE PRESIDENT’S
STRATEGY.
WE WANT TO PREVENT THE
CORONAVIRUS FROM BEING BROUGHT
INTO THE COUNTRY AND THEN
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON THOSE
COMMUNITIES WHERE WE HAVE
COMMUNITY SPREAD EVEN AS WE
ENCOURAGE BEST PRACTICES AND
COMMON SENSE BY EVERY AMERICAN.
AINSLEY: MR. VICE PRESIDENT WHAT
DO YOU SAY TO THOSE FAMILIES
THAT ARE KIDS IN COLLEGE
TRAVELING ABROAD, STUDYING
ABROAD.
I KNOW IF THEY’RE IN ITALY HAVE
TO STAY PUT.
WHAT ABOUT ABOUT KIDS IN
SWITZERLAND AND IRELAND AND
FRANCE?
>> AINSLEY, IT’S A GREAT
QUESTION AND I HAVE HAD KIDS
THAT HAVE STUDIED ABROAD AS WELL
EVERYONE ONE OF THOSE FAMILIES
SHOULD KNOW THAT THEIR CHILDREN
CAN COME HOME.
THEY WILL BE FUNNELED AS WE SAY
THROUGH A SERIES OF 13 DIFFERENT
AIRPORTS.
AND THEN WE WILL ASK THEM TO
SELF-QUARANTINE REGARDLESS OF
THEIR SYMPTOMS OR WHAT THEIR
CONDITION.
AINSLEY: SHOULD THEY COME HOME
OR COULD THEY STAY?
>> WELL, LOOK, I WOULD SUGGEST
TO YOU THAT NOW THAT WE SEE THAT
70% OF THE NEW CORONAVIRUS CASES
IN THIS COUNTRY OR IN THE WORLD
ARE NOW BEING MANIFEST IN
EUROPE, I WOULD LEAVE THAT
DECISION TO EVERY FAMILY, BUT
THERE IS NO BARRIER TO THEIR
KIDS OR ANY AMERICAN COMING
HOME.
THEY WILL GO THROUGH A PROCESS.
WE WILL ASK THEM TO
SELF-QUARANTINE.
BUT, THEY CAN ALL COME HOME.
BRIAN: SO, MR. VICE PRESIDENT,
62,000 CHINESE CITIZENS HAVE
BEEN DISCHARGED FROM THE
HOSPITAL.
THEY KNOW -- IF WE ARE TO
BELIEVE THEM THEY ONLY HAD 15
CASES THE OTHER DAY, EIGHT OF
WHICH ARE FROM CHINESE CITIZENS,
16 FROM THE OUTSIDE.
IF SUCCESS LEAVES CLUES AND THAT
MASSIVE QUARANTINE OF ENTIRE
CITIES HAS GOT THE NUMBER DOWN
THAT LOW, ARE YOU -- DO YOU
THINK WE SHOULD END UP -- SHOULD
WE DO THE SAME THING AS CHINA
DID?
AFTER ALL, THEY STARTED THE
WHOLE THING AND THEY SEEM TO BE
ON TOP OF THIS NOW.
>> WELL, WE ARE SEEING SOME
ENCOURAGING NEWS FROM ASIA AND
THE PRESIDENT LAST NIGHT IN HIS
ADDRESS TO THE NATION SAID THAT
WE MAY BE ABLE TO RECONSIDER OUR
CURRENT POSTURE WITH REGARD TO
CHINA AND SOUTH KOREA AS A
RESULT.
BUT, MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT,
BRIAN, OUR FOCUS HERE, IN
ADDITION TO PREVENTING THE
CORONAVIRUS FROM BEING BROUGHT
IN, AND WHAT WE LEARNED FROM OUR
HEALTH EXPERTS IN THE LAST 36
HOURS WAS THAT YESTERDAY, AS OF
THE 35 CASES WHERE WE HAD
CORONAVIRUS CASES, ABOUT 30 OF
THOSE STATES, 35 STATES, 30 OF
THOSE STATES ACTUALLY COULD
TRACE THE CONTACT TO SOMEONE IN
EUROPE.
THAT’S THE REASON THE PRESIDENT
TOOK THE DECISIVE ACTION HE
TOOK.
BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT, WE
ARE ALSO FOCUSING ON SUPPORTING
EFFORTS AT THE STATE AND LOCAL
LEVEL IN CALIFORNIA, IN
WASHINGTON STATE, AND IN
CALIFORNIA, CDC ISSUED VERY
STRONG GUIDELINES FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES ABOUT PUBLIC
ACTIVITIES, LARGE GATHERINGS,
SCHOOLS AND WE’LL CONTINUE
SIMPLY TO FOLLOW THE DATA ON
THIS AND MAKE STRONG
RECOMMENDATIONS WHERE WE HAVE
WHAT’S KNOWN AS COMMUNITY SPREAD
STEVE STEVE RIGHT, BUT FOR EVERY
AMERICAN RIGHT NOW AS THE
PRESIDENT SAID LAST NIGHT, IT’S
A GOOD TIME TO USE COMMON SENSE.
WASH YOUR HANDS OFTEN.
CLEAN, YOU KNOW, OFTEN USE USED
SURFACES.
ALL THAT INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE AT CORONAVIRUS.GOV.
WE WILL TRY TO MITIGATE THE
SPREAD IN THIS COUNTRY BUT ALSO
PREVENT THROUGH THE PRESIDENT’S
DECISIVE ACTION LAST NIGHT
PEOPLE FROM BRINGING CORONAVIRUS
IN TO THE UNITED STATES FROM
EUROPE.
BRIAN: JUST TO CLARIFY, YOU ARE
NOT GOING TO DO WHAT THEY DID IN
WUHAN YOU ARE NOT GOING TO SAY
MANHATTAN YOU ARE LOCKED DOWN.
SACRAMENTO, YOU ARE LOCKED DOWN.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO DO THAT AS
OF NOW EVEN THOUGH THEY DID THAT
IN CHINA?
>> WELL, WHAT I PROMISE YOU,
BRIAN, WE WILL WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH STATE AND LOCAL OFFICIALS
TO GIVE THEM THE VERY BEST
COUNSEL FROM CDC AND HEALTHCARE
EXPERTS.
I TALKED TO THE MAYOR OF NEW
ROCHELLE YESTERDAY.
I KNOW THEY HAVE ESTABLISHED A
ZONE IN THEIR COMMUNITY FOR
EXTRA COUNTER MEASURES AGAINST
CORONAVIRUS.
I TALKED TO THE GOVERNOR OF NEW
YORK, WASHINGTON STATE AND
CALIFORNIA YESTERDAY ABOUT NEW
SPECIFIC GUIDELINES FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
BUT I WANT TO SAY TO YOUR
VIEWERS JUST AS THE PRESIDENT
SAID LAST NIGHT, THE RISK TO THE
AVERAGE AMERICAN OF CONTRACTING
THE CORONAVIRUS REMAINS LOW.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT SENIORS WITH
SERIOUS UNDERLYING CHRONIC
HEALTH CONDITIONS ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO VERY
SERIOUS OUTCOMES.
AND SO WE ARE ENCOURAGING BEST
PRACTICES FOR EVERY AMERICAN.
WE’RE FOCUSING ON COMMUNITIES
WHERE WE HAVE COMMUNITY SPREAD.
STEVE: RIGHT.
>> FOR ANY AMERICAN THAT’S
WATCHING TODAY THAT HAS A FAMILY
MEMBER, A LOVED ONE WHO IS A
SENIOR CITIZEN WITH A SERIOUS
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITION,
THIS IS A VERY GOOD TIME TO HELP
AND TO SUPPORT THEM TO BE ABLE
TO AVOID PUBLIC PLACES AND
EVERYONE AROUND THEM TO ENGAGE
IN GOOD HYGIENE AND GOOD
PRACTICES TO PROTECT THOSE THAT
ARE MOST VULNERABLE.
STEVE: AND THE KEY IS WHAT IS
NOW REFERRED TO, MR. VICE
PRESIDENT, AS SOCIAL DISTANCING.
WHERE YOU JUST KEEP A DISTANCE
FROM PEOPLE AROUND YOU.
IF YOU HAVE GOT TO GO TO THE
GROCERY STORE, DON’T COME UP
RIGHT BEHIND THEM.
YOU JUST NEVER KNOW WHO MIGHT
HAVE IT.
I KNOW THE PRESIDENT HAS CALLED
OFF HIS DOMESTIC TRAVEL.
POSTPONED A RALLY AND
FUNDRAISING EVENT.
WE KNOW THAT THE NBA HAS
SUSPENDED THEIR SEASON.
THE NCAA IS GOING TO DO MARCH
MADNESS WITHOUT PEOPLE IN THE
STANDS FOR THE MOST PART.
AND THEN HAVE YOU GOT ANTHONY
FAUCI YESTERDAY WHO SAID IT’S
PROBABLY GOING TO GET WORSE
BEFORE IT GETS BETTER.
THERE IS A STORY OUT AS WELL
THAT SAYS THAT LAST WEEK
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS WERE
TOLD THERE IS A GOOD CHANCE THAT
MOST PEOPLE IN THE UNITED STATES
WILL BE EXPOSED TO IT.
DOESN’T MEAN THEY ARE GOING TO
GET IT BUT IT COULD BE OUT
THERE.
>> RIGHT.
WELL, LOOK, ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS FROM OUR EXPERTS
STUDYING GLOBAL DATA IS IT’S TWO
TO THREE TIMES MORE CONTAGIOUS
AS A RESPIRATORY ILLNESS.
SO WE WILL HAVE THOUSANDS OF
MORE CASES ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
BUT, YOUR VIEWERS DESERVE TO
KNOW THAT MOST AMERICANS, THE
VAST MAJORITY OF AMERICANS WHO
EVEN CONTRACT THE CORONAVIRUS
WILL HAVE FLU LIKE SYMPTOMS AND
WILL FULLY RECOVER.
I TALKED TO A MAN NAMED CLAY
BENTLEY IN ROME, GEORGIA
YESTERDAY ON THE PHONE.
HE IS DOING WELL.
IS HE RECOVERING WELL.
AND HIS PERSONAL STRENGTH AND
HIS FAITH HAVE SUSTAINED HIM
THROUGH.
THIS AND IT WAS INSPIRING TO
TALK TO HIM.
SO, WE DON’T WANT, AS THE
PRESIDENT HAS CONVEYED.
WE DON’T WANT AMERICANS TO BE
OVERLY CONCERNED.
WE WANT EVERYBODY TO PRACTICE
GOOD COMMON SENSE.
STEVE: SURE.
>> IN THOSE COMMUNITIES WHERE WE
HAVE COMMUNITY SPREAD, WE WILL
CONTINUE TO GIVE VERY AGGRESSIVE
RECOMMENDATION AS WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA AND WASHINGTON AND
NEW YORK TO DO EXACTLY WHAT YOU
ARE SAYING WITH REGARD TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
AND WE’LL RESPECT THE DECISIONS
OF ANY BUSINESS, ANY SPORTS
ENTERPRISE THAT DECIDES TO
CANCEL EVENTS TO PUT THE HEALTH
OF THE COUNTRY FIRST.
BUT IT’S REALLY IMPORTANT -- I
REALLY BELIEVE TO FOCUS ON THE
MOST VULNERABLE.
SENIORS WITH SERIOUS UNDERLYING
HEALTH CONDITIONS.
IT’S THE REASON WHY WE ARE
FOCUSING MORE INSPECTIONS.
RAISED THE GUIDELINES AT NURSING
HOMES AND RECOMMENDING THAT
PEOPLE OTHER THAN THOSE THAT
HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS INS WHO PIT
CARE, SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES
AVOID VISITING NURSING HOMES
OVER THE NEXT 30 DAYS.
AINSLEY: I LOVE THAT A LOT OF
THESE BUSINESSES ARE MAKING
SMART DECISIONS.
I KNOW THE FINANCIAL MARKET,
MANY OF THE BANKS HERE ARE
SAYING CAN YOU WORK FROM HOME.
CAN YOU TRAVEL TO SEE YOUR
FAMILY AND STAY THERE AND JUST
KEEP YOUR PHONE CLOSE BY AND
WORK USING YOUR COMPUTER.
WHAT ABOUT THE MASKS -- EXCUSE
ME, NOT THE MASKS THE TESTS.
IF YOU FEEL LIKE HAVE YOU THOSE
SYMPTOMS AND YOU CALL YOUR
DOCTOR, BEFORE YOU SHOW UP,
RIGHT?
IS THAT WHAT WE ARE SUPPOSED TO
DO CALL IN ADVANCE SO YOU DON’T
WALK IN AND INFECT OTHER PEOPLE?
>> YES.
AINSLEY: DO WE HAVE ENOUGH TESTS
OUT THERE.
>> AINSLEY WE ARE WORKING EVERY
SINGLE DAY TO CLEAR OUT ANY RED
TAPE TO MAKE TESTS MORE AND MORE
AVAILABLE.
RIGHT NOW EVERY STATE LAB IN
AMERICA CAN CONDUCT TESTING.
ANYONE OF YOUR VIEWERS THAT MAY
HAVE A CONCERN CAN CALL THEIR
DOCTOR.
THEIR DOCTOR CAN CONTACT THE
STATE LAB AND DETERMINE HOW TO
GET A TEST PROCESSED.
I’M ALSO PROUD OF THE FACT THAT
UNIVERSITY HOSPITALS AROUND THE
COUNTRY ARE CONDUCTING TESTS.
THE UNIVERSITY OF WASHINGTON IS
DOING A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
TESTING.
RIGHT NOW FOR THEIR CITIZENS
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY THE
CORONAVIRUS.
BUT, LASTLY, THE PRESIDENT, YOU
KNOW, HE SAID THIS WAS A WHOLE
OF GOVERNMENT APPROACH, BUT HE
ALSO SAID THIS IS A WHOLE OF
AMERICA APPROACH.
SO HE HAS BROUGHT IN BUSINESS
LEADERS FROM NURSING HOMES,
YESTERDAY BANKING, HOSPITALS,
AND THE REST, BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS WE DID THAT’S MOST
IMPORTANT ON TESTING WAS THE
PRESIDENT BROUGHT IN THE LEADERS
OF THE TOP COMMERCIAL
LABORATORIES IN THE COUNTRY WHO,
AS WE SPEAK, HAVE ALREADY
APPROVED A TEST THAT IS BEING
SPUN UP, IT’S BEING SENT OUT TO
MARKET, QUEST, LABCORP, THE
LARGEST COMMERCIAL LABORATORIES
IN THE COUNTRY ARE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH OUR ADMINISTRATION.
WE’RE CLEARING THE RED TAPE OUT
OF THE WAY.
THAT’S GOING TO BE THE WAY THAT
IN THE DAYS AHEAD WE ARE GOING
TO HAVE A BROAD-BASED TESTING
AVAILABLE ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
BRIAN: RIGHT.
JUST IN TERMS OF THE NUMBERS
THAT WE WOKE UP WITH.
WORLDWIDE 118,000 CASES.
U.S. CONFIRMED 1110.:  DEATHS 36
48 STATES AFFECTED INCLUDING
WASHINGTON, D.C.
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO EXPAND
ON THAT?
>> NO.
THOSE ARE THE NUMBERS.
I HAVEN’T GOTTEN MY FULL
BRIEFING YET THIS MORNING.
BUT THOSE -- THE NUMBERS THAT WE
REALLY FOCUSED ON IN THE
PRESIDENT’S DECISION YESTERDAY
THOUGH BRIAN WAS THE FACT THAT
IT -- TWO WEEKS AGO, ITALY HAD
ROUGHLY 500 CASES.
AS OF YESTERDAY, THEY HAVE
12,000 CASES.
GERMANY WAS AT ANOTHER THOUSAND.
FRANCE AT ANOTHER THOUSAND.
THAT’S WHY THE PRESIDENT
RECOGNIZED THAT THE EPICENTER OF
THE CORONAVIRUS HAS SHIFTED FROM
CHINA AND SOUTH KOREA TO EUROPE.
AND THAT’S WHY HE TOOK THE
UNPRECEDENTED STEP, SAME THING
HE DONE WITH CHINA TO SUSPEND
ALL TRAVEL FOR 30 DAYS FROM
EUROPE.
IT’S ABOUT PREVENTING THE
ADDITIONAL FLOW OF THE INFECTION
FROM EUROPE INTO OUR COUNTRY.
BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT.
WE ARE ALSO AT THE SAME TIME
FOCUSING ON MITIGATION
STRATEGIES IN COMMUNITIES WHERE
WE HAVE COMMUNITY SPREAD.
WE’RE ENCOURAGING BEST PRACTICES
FOR EVERY AMERICAN, ESPECIALLY
FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION.
AND MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT,
OUR GOAL AS THE CORONAVIRUS
SPREADS IN THIS COUNTRY, IN THE
VAST MAJORITY WHO WOULD CONTRACT
IT WILL HAVE FLU-LIKE SYMPTOMS
AND RECOVER.
OUR GOAL, NONETHELESS, IS TO
HOLD DOWN THAT OVERALL NUMBER AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND WE WILL DO
THAT WITH THE CONTINUING
COOPERATION OF AMERICAN
FAMILIES, SCHOOLS, BUSINESSES,
AND STATES, AND THAT’S THE
VISION PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS.
ALL OF US WORKING TOGETHER WILL
GET THROUGH THIS.
STEVE: WELL, THESE CERTAINLY ARE
CHALLENGING TIMES AND IT’S GOOD
TO NOTE PRESIDENT AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAVE A PLAN.
MR. VICE PRESIDENT, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
WE KNOW YOU ARE A VERY BUSY MAN